in this scene from this year's Best
Picture winner parasite one of the
protagonists key tech discovers the
reason the bulbs in the parks mansion
light up when the residents walk up the
stairs it's one of those reveals that's
led many critics and fans to describe
the film as surprising but if you've
seen director bong Joon hos 2013 movies
snowpiercer it might feel familiar
consider this moment when the film's
main character Kurtis discovers how the
train he's riding keeps running
[Music]
the space only allows for a very small
person each protagonist observes
mechanical operations that are revealed
to be the result of a human being
trapped in a small space repeating the
same action over and over and if you
look more closely you'll see that this
isn't the only image recycled from one
movie to the other several of bonds
films employ the same visuals sometimes
the same shots to ask the same
conceptual questions in fact parasite
can be understood as a second more
perfect version of snowpiercer
one of the sharpest clues that the two
films are linked is a dramatic panning
shot used about 40 minutes into parasite
those how much
let's add some context in this scene mr.
Park the head of the wealthy household
at the center of the film has a
conversation with key tech who is
working as his driver when key tech asks
an intimate question about mr. parks
life
mr. Park is taken aback offended as he
states earlier in the same scene in
reference to his old housekeeper kill Mr
Bond positions the characters diagonally
across from each other cutting from one
side of mr. parks face to the other side
of ki-tak's face in contrast to more
traditionally blocked films that feature
conversations and vehicles in which two
figures are shot from the same side and
bongs set up the 180 degree rule is
broken the two characters divided
narrative Lee by economic and social
status are also quarantined visually by
their opposite relationship with the
camera until when the camera pans the
two characters are finally brought
together in the same cinematic space
emphasizing their transition from
divided to close mr. parks line has been
crossed now let's look at the moment
when bond uses the same shot in
snowpiercer
18 years I've waited for this moment if
parasite is a film about people trapped
by lines of class hierarchy snowpiercer
is a film that takes place entirely on a
line
the film's premise is that because of an
environmental collapse that is left
behind only frozen wasteland the
remaining humans must survive by riding
a train that encircles the earth forever
each train car represents a different
segment of society from those living in
luxury near the engine to the resource
impoverished tail section Kurtis leads a
linear revolt from the back of the Train
to the front in this scene another
character refuses to help him break
through the final gate to the engine
room instead he has a different plan
you do moony-eyed it up did you want to
get away and that's when we get this
shot
he wants to bomb open the side door
freaking the line of the train and
walked perpendicularly out into the
world in both films bongs camera often
pans in moments when characters first
break across or sabotage systems of
class hierarchy he also pays close
attention to architectural lines
parasite is a very vertical film while
the world of snowpiercer by design is
horizontal Kozma the second motif that
binds the two films is the way that
information takes on the physical
appearance of guns and bullets in
parasite moon Guang threatens to send
the park family a video recording that
would expose the Kim family scheme she
and her husband control the family
physically with this object wielding the
truth like a gun in snowpiercer Curtis
receives vital messages rolled into
bullet shapes these notes guide his
bloody path through the hierarchy of the
Train by providing him pieces of
information that place him one step
ahead of the otherwise impenetrable
armies that stand in his way
it's also curtis's revelation that the
guns forcing the tail section residents
to comply have no bullets that enables
the first step of his revolution
by using imagery that turns information
into deadly weapons both films bring up
the idea that psychological constraints
are as powerful as physical ones this
idea is important to keep in mind as we
turn back to the third motif that links
the two films together in both parasite
and snowpiercer
the protagonists realized that
mechanical operations they've observed
earlier in the film are sustained by
hidden human parts
[Music]
snowpiercer wasn't the first time bong
used this type of imagery in his 2006
movie the host the government turns the
main character into a lab subject in
order to contain panic about a virus
outbreak he is packaged stamped and
poked like an object the virus must be
in here it has got to be
in many of bongs films protagonists
struggle furiously to escape the
unchecked capitalist or authoritarian
systems that dehumanize them in contrast
the victims in Snow piercers engine are
not shown to be physically restrained
even as Curtis shouts at him to stop one
of the small boys crawls out of the
container and walks a zombie-like into
the hungry engine parasite takes us a
step further rather than a child
intimidated into obedience by adults an
adult man sneaks into the basement and
lives there banging the light switch
levers every day by choice thank you got
ya it was economic hardship that led gun
se to become a fugitive but he Revere's
people who have financial and political
power
similarly no matter how many times
ki-woo his plans fail or he observes
wealthy people act in ways that are
pathetic or grotesque
he clings to his dream of attaining what
they have don't you in the final moments
of parasite we as the audience
participate in his fantasy in a sequence
just heartbreaking enough and long
enough that we believe it's real
[Music]
throughout parasite ki-woo often repeats
the phrase just how much I'm doing gonna
do it why just do it all this
increasingly empty and comical phrase
pokes fun at the way people often use
words not to express any actual meaning
but to indicate cultural status but it
can also be understood as a
self-deprecating joke many of bongs past
films use otherworldly science fiction
concedes as allegories for systemic
social issues parasite on the other hand
is about something more visceral and
more human our tendency to react to
social hierarchy not with resistance or
compassion but with desire and disgust
you
[Music]